ترحيبها باعلان المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
ان ما شاهده غرب دارفور من فضاعات بحق
المدنيين سيكون محل تحقيقات ومساءلات
قضائيه وحملت واشنطن قوه الدعم المسؤوليه
عن تلك الانتهاكات وهو ما نفاه الدعم
داعيا لتحقيق مستقل في احداث الجنينه
يتزامن ذلك مع ترحيب طرفي المواجهات
بمخرجات قمه القاهره لدول الجوار السوداني
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كندا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
دلاله ردود الفعل الدوليه المندده بما
يتعرض له المدنيون في دارفور من فضاعات
واعلان الجنائيه الدوليه انها ستكون محل
تحقيقات وملاحقات قضائيه وسط اتهامات
لقوات الدعم بالوقوف وراءها
ومرهانات التي تقف وراء استهداف المدنيين
بتلك الوحشيه في دارفور وغيرها رغم ما
تثير من ردود فعل بين الدول والهيئات
الدوليه بانواعها
[موسيقى]
احداث داميه وانتهاكات خطيره لحقوق
الانسان ذهب ضحيتها عشرات المدنيين غربيه
دارفور توقظ بحسب المدعي العام للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ذاكره سودانيه مسخنه
باحداث مماثله جرت في الماضي القريب ودفعت
مجلس الامن حينها لاحاله ملف السودان الى
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه كريم خان قال
امام مجلس الامن انه سيجري التحقيق في
كافه الانتهاكات ومحاسبه مرتكبيها عبر
محاكمات عادله خطوه رحبت بها الخارجيه
الامريكيه التي اكدت ان تقارير عن مقابر
جماعيه في مصر والجنينه تقدم ادله اضافيه
على فضائع الدعم السريع
اتهامات نفتها قوات الدعم قائله ان احدا
من مقاتليها لم يتورط في احداث الجنينه
وانها تقبل باي تحقيق مستقل يميت اللثام
عن الحقيقه
وفيما تنشط المساعي الاقليميه والدوليه
لانهاء الازمه شهدت العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم اشتباكات عنيفه وواسعه بين قوات
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع رافقها سماع دوي
اسلحه ثقيله استخدمت في المواجهات
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من باريس محمد
تورشين الكاتب والباحث السياسيه السوداني
ومن ميشيغان السفيره سوزان بيج نائبه
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق
للشؤون الافريقيه والمستشاره السابقه
للمبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى السودان كما
ينضم الينا من بيروت الدكتور بول مرقص
استاذ القانون الدولي ورئيس منظمه
جوستيسيا
الحقوقيه ابدا معك سيد محمد
السودان في ضوء هذه المواقف وهذه التطورات
احاله ما وصف بفضائع في غرب دارفور من
جديد الى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه هل هو
امام منعطف سياسيا وقانونيا جديدا قديم
ك الاقارب انا في تقديري هذا تطور مهم جدا
للغايه في محاوله رغبه المحكمه الجنائي
الدوليه
لاحداث العداله
تعرضون الانتهاكات منذ مطلع العام 2002 من
قبل نفس المجموعه وهي قوات الدعم السريعه
باختلاف المسميات باعتبار من قبل كانت في
اطار حرس الحدود من قبل كانت في اطار غير
منظمه سميشيات
الحكومه السودانيه لم تستجيب في احد
النظام الرباعي بقياده عمر البشير وحتى في
ايمان الفتره الانتقاليه لم تكن هناك
استجابه
وكامل مع المحكمه الجنائي الدوليه
في تسليم المتهمين سواء كانت عمر البشير
او عبد الرحيم محمد حسين واحمد هارون فضلا
عن ذلك بعض القيادات التي تتبع للحركات
المسلحه
او تسليم علي عن طريق تنسيق من بعض
الافراد خارج اطار الحكومه السودانيه
فبالتالي انا في تقدير هذه الخطوه ستضع
الحكومه السودانيه والتحدي حقيقي هل
ستستجيب في ظل اتزاع بعد الانتهاكات هذه
الالتهابات لم تقتصر فقط على الجنان وانما
شملت حتى الخرطوم من جرائم التعذيب وكذلك
اعتداء على المدنين والاختصابات وما الى
ذلك فبالتالي في ظل ضعف القضاء السوداني
انا في تقديره ينبغي الان على السلطات
السودانيه بتتعامل بشكل جد وبشكل عقلاني
مع المحكمه ان ما حدث في غرب دارفور هي
جرائم ينده لها الجبين ولا يمكن باي حال
من الاح
وال ان يتقبلها سواء الحكومه السودانيه
وقوات الدعم
السري ظلت ترفض هذه الانتهاك بتقدير هذه
الانتهاكات هي من صميم التركيب البنيويه
لها ويتدوران هذه المجموعات تعتمد في
الاصل على
في ترتيباتها
كيف يمكن ان يفسر موقف الولايات المتحده
هذا الموقف الذي انتقل من موقع الوسيط حتى
الامس القريبه الى موقع المتهم بشده لقوات
الدعم السريع بانها هي من تقف وراء
الفضائع في غرب دارفور وتدعم احاله الملف
الى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
وبشخص المدعي العام كون
قد اوضحت
[موسيقى]
انه
بموجب التحقيقات المفتوحه القائمه
والمستمره في قضيه دارفور هناك احتمال بان
يتم النظر في كافه هذه الجرائم والتحقيق
فيها
بموجب الصلاحيات القائمه
والتي حيز التنفيذ والولايات المتحده قدمت
الدعم لهذه التحقيقات لاحتمال ان تكون هذه
الجرائم ضد الانسانيه
ومشاجر جمعيه هنالك وكل ذلك ينضوي تحت
سلطه المحكمه الجنائيه الدولية سؤالي في
الاطار السياسي يعني موقف الولايات
المتحده
هل هو مجرد موقف انساني بحث ام له خلفيات
سياسيه
بحسب ما فهمته طبعا الولايات المتحده تريد
ان تتوقف الحرب وهي تقف ضد اي تدخل اجنبي
اذا كان ذلك سوف يؤدي الى انتشار الحرب
وخروجها من حدود السودان طبعا الولايات
المتحده تريد السلام وتريد اليه او نظاما
جديدا بحسب ما يطالب به الشعب وليس فقط
تقف وراء المساعدات الانسانيه تريد اكثر
من ذلك
مرقس في الاطار القانوني الى اين مدى يمكن
ان نقول ان اليوم يشبه الامس قبل حوالي 20
سنه عندما كان ملف السودان ايضا امام
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ولكن بعناوين
مختلفه كما ذكر ضيفنا من باريس تحت عناوين
حرس الحدود او قوات الجنجاويد اليوم قوه
الدعم السريع
هذا سؤال مهم نعم هنالك تقاطع فعلا يعني
مميز نتيجه ان المنطقه الجغرافيه هي نفسها
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه الدائمه هي
المعنيه لكن المعطيات اختلفت من حيث
التراكميه التي تقوم عليها هذه المساله
بمعنى اننا وراء 300 الف ضحيه في العقد
الاول من القرن الحالي امام اربعه مذكرات
توقيف امام احاله متجدده اذا هنالك فعل
تراكمي ممكن له ان يحفز هذا المسار من
التحقيق جنائي الدولي وبالتالي الا تشبه
النتيجه التي سيؤول اليها هذه المره الا
تشبه ما افضت اليها التحقيقات السابقه
والاجراءات السابقه انما نحن لا زلنا
اليوم امام طلب فتح تحقيق من المدعي العام
وبالتالي امام توثيق هذه في الجرائم
المتعلقه بالجرائم ضد الانسانيه جرائم
الحرب الفظاعات المتعلقه بالمدنيين السكان
العزه الاطفال الاغتصاب كل ما ينتهك فعلا
اتفاقيات جنيف الاربعه لعام 1949 نحن امام
هذا التوثيق الذي يمكن ان يؤدي الى
المحاكمه لكننا لم نبلغ بعد مرحله
المحاكمه نحن متجهون اليها اذا استمرت
الاجواء ايجابيه في مجلس الامن الدولي
تعرف معي ان المجلس الامن هو الممر
السياسي الالزامي للعداله الجنائيه
الدوليه للاسف الشديد
المحاسبه القانونيه يجب ان تمر بهذا الباب
السياسي وما ادراك ما هي تركيبه مجلس
الامن الدولي تعرف تماما حق التعطيل
الفيتو الذي يمكن ان يمارس المصالح
الدوليه الكبرى انما اليوم على الاقل كريم
خان يطلق صرخه مدويه ويراكم على ما بني من
سوابق فظيعه في الشان السوداني المتعلق في
الافلات من العقاب يعني هذا المسار
السياسي يقود الى سؤال ضيفنا محمد تورشين
من باريس ان كان هذا الملف يمكن ان يكون
ملفا ضاغطا على
الاطراف السودانيه على الدعم السريع بشكل
خاص من اجل الخضوع والتنازل ربما او
الوصول الى حل سياسي ما باعتبار ان
المساله مرتبطه بمجلس الامن وتصويت مجلس
الامن قبل ان يصل الملف الى المحكمه
هو بلا شك قوات الدعم السريع ومنذ ان نعرض
هذه الصفه في العامه 2013 وكانت تتبع
لجهاز الامن والمخابرات
وكذلك في في شرعنتها في 2017 باعتبار قوه
تابعه لرئاسه الجمهوريه اصبحت تبذل
المجهودات كبيره جدا في اطار تحسين صورته
في اطار ان تحظى بمشروعيه سواء كان
مشروعيه داخل البلاد في السودان او
مشروعيه اقليم الدوليه وفي اطار ذلك عملت
بشكل كبير جدا في اطارنا تقوم بادوار
كبيره جدا في اطار محاربه الهجره غير
الشرعيه والجماعات غير
المنظمه فيه في مع الاتحاد الاوروبي ففي
اطار ذلك انا في تقدير من الصعب جدا ان
تستمر هذه الاتهامات دون ان تقوم وقت
الدعم السريعه وتاخده خطوات نحولها وفي
اطار ساحتها سواء كان من خلال التعاون في
اطار تحقيق دوري مستقل حتى تقدم بعض
العناصر او بعض الافراد باعتبارهم الامم
المتهمين وهم الذين قاموا ارتكاب مثل هذه
العامه فباي حال من الاحوال مثل هذه
الاتهامات في تقدير خطيره جدا وستجعل
الكثير من القوى الاقليميه تعيد النظر
في العقوات الدعم السريع سواء كان الاتحاد
الاوروبي او الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبعض حتى
القوه السياسيه التي ظلت تتعاطى وتتعامل
مع قوات الدعم السريع باعتبار ان هذه
الجرائم تعيد بنايه الى الوراء والى
الالتهابات التي ظلت بهذه النقطه
اذا كانت هذه الفضاءات وهذه الجرائم كما
تقول تعود بنا الى الوراء وتتحدث عن نفس
الاطراف لكن بمسميات اخرى لماذا تكرر عفوا
لماذا تكرر هذه الاطراف
وعلامات تراهن في
يعني القيام بهذه الاعمال المتهمه بها
حاليا في دارفور
تمارس هذه الالتهابات وهذه الجرائب الامر
الاساسي يعود الى تركيبه هذه القوات
وطبيعتها هذه القوات تنتمي الى مجموعات
مثنيه لديها اشكاليه وخلافات تاريخيه مع
بعض المجموعات
او السكان الاصليين في المنطقه فبالتالي
دائما الصراع كان في الماضي يضم في اطار
الصراع على الارض
والان بفعل سياسات النظام البعد بتجييش
بعض القبائل ضد المجموعات التي ملتهمه
بانها تمردت على نظام الخرطوم وابسط هنا
الحركات المسلحه استطاع انه يوفر لهذه
المجموعات سلاح خارج الاطر القانونيه دون
ان يتلقوا تدريب والدرعات عسكريه كافيه
وكذلك اعتراف
باحترام حقوق الانسان باحترام القانون
الدولي تعالوا يستغلون هذه الصفات شبه
الرسميه اطار الانتقام في اطار تحقيق
المكاسب
وفي طويل اجل تحقيق مكاسب من اجل السيطره
على بعض الاراضي وبعض المناطق وكذلك تحقيق
بعض المكاسب الاقتصاديه سيده سوزان بيدج
هل يعكس موقف الولايات المتحده الداعم
للجنائيه الداوديه او لتحقيقات المدعي
العام والاتهام السريع لقوات الدعم بانها
هي من تقوم
بتلك الفضاءات بناء على تقارير تقول
للولايات المتحده ان موثوقه هذا الموقف هل
يعكس استياء امريكيا من الوصول الى حل
سياسي في السودان
انا لا اعتقد ان الموضوع مرتبط بالعجز عن
التوصل الى حل سياسي ولكنه اعتراف بان
المساءله
والعدالهما في جوهر بعض المشاكل
القائمه ليس فقط في دارفور بل في كافه
انحاء السودان وبالتالي من المهم بالنسبه
الى الولايات المتحده ودول اخرى ومنظمات
اخرى ان تقف خلف او تقف داعمه
لهذه التحقيقات
في الفضاء التي ارتكبها مهما كانت طرف
نقطه اخيره يجب ان نناوه بها كل ما يحال
الى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
له علاقه بالمسؤوليه الفرديه نحن لا نتحدث
عن قوات الدعم السريع ككيان بل نتحدث عن
افراد اشخاص هم الذين ارتكبوا هذه الفظائع
على اي اساس تقولين ذلك يعني حسب بيان
الخارجيه الامريكيه لا يبدو ان الامر
مرتبط
باقله من حيث اللغه او اللهجه بحسب بيان
الخارجيه الامريكيه واتهام للدعم السريع
كمنظمه او كقوات عسكريه وليس كافراد او
كمسولين
هذا صحيح نعم هذا ما افاد به البيان ولكن
لو استمرت هذه التحقيقات ومضت بها قدما
هذه المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه المحكمه
مبنيه على اساس المسؤوليه الجنائيه
الفرديه بموجب القانون او نظام تاسيسي لها
وبالتالي حين نتحدث عن ادانه اي شخص او اي
طرف الادانه لا تكون لي قوات الدعم السريع
يجب ان يدينوا اشخاصا افرادا يعتبرون انهم
ارتكبوا هذه الفضائع هذه الجرائم
ما رايك
بهذه الجزئيه الهامه جدا المسؤوليه
الفرديه وليس مسؤوليه
قوات او منظمه او هيئه معينه بل مسؤوليه
افراد يكونون قد ارتكبوا تلك الفضاءات
هذا في المبدا ونظريا امر صحيح لان نظام
روما لعام 1998 الذي انشات على اساسه
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه الدائمه نعم هو
يلقي المسؤوليه الفرديه على الاشخاص
الطبيعيين الافراد وليس على الكيانات
المعنويه الاشخاص الاعتباريين يعني مثل
الدول او الاحزاب او المنظمات
العسكريتاريه والميليشيات فهو اذا يدين اي
المحكمه تدين عند صدور الحكم الاشخاص
الطبيعيين الافراد لكن اذا ادين مسؤولون
او جنود او يعني قاده فان لذلك رمزي كبرى
فتكون الاذانه نعم هي ادانا شخصيه افراديه
لكن عواقب ومؤده هذا الامر ومفاعله
على الشخص الاعتباري المعنوي الذي يمثلونه
خلال القيام بهذه المعارك وهنا اعطي مثل
حديث عندما اودين افراد من حزب الله مثلا
في المحكمه الخاصه بلبنان منذ سنين وبصرف
النظر عن راينا في مسار المحكمه وفيما
قالت اليه لكن الادانه الفرديه انما ايضا
ترمز الى الانضواء لهؤلاء والانتماء الى
حزب معين او منظمه هنالك علما انها كانت
علما انها كانت كانت محكمه خاصه وليست
محكمه جنائيه لكن اود منك
باختصار وهذا هذا كان منصوص في
في نص تشكيل المحكمه الخاصه سؤالي بالنسبه
لموضوع موضوع
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه برايك وباختصار
ايه عوائق يمكن ان تقف
او تعرقل عملها في سياق السياسي هذه المره
بالنظر الى وضعيه السودان
نعم
باختصار تغير المصالح السياسيه الدوليه
المتمثله بالدول الخمس دائمه العضويه في
مجلس الامن خصوصا التي تسمى دولا عظمى وهي
عظمى بسبب نفوذها العسكري بينما دول اخرى
هي عظمى اليوم بسبب احترامها حقوق الانسان
مثلا وليست عضوا دائما في مجلس الامن ولا
تمارس حق النقد ولكن امرين اخرين باختصار
اريد ان اقولهما دعوه كريم خام الذي كريم
خال الذي وجبته في لهاي في المحكمه الخاصه
بلبنان واعرف عمله يوم كان محاميا هذا
الرجل اليوم بمجرد انه اطلق العنان لهذا
المسار التحقيقي الجنائي الدولي قام بخطوه
ردعيه تجاه المقاتلين وقال ذلك بمكان معين
عندما توجه اليهم ثانيا وباختصار فان هذه
الخطوه ايضا ممكن ان تحفز مسار السياسي في
السودان تجاه دارفور باتجاه حل الخلافات
وتعرف معي نقطه اخيره ان المحاكم
والتحقيقات الجنائيه تاتي في المطاف
الاخير ربما من هذه الازمات والنزاعات
الدوليه للاسف نعم سيد محمد تورشين هل
توافق الراي على انها يمكن ان تكون
حافزا يعني هذه المحاكمات او هذه التيامات
يمكن ان تكون حافزا نحو الوصول الى حل
سياسي او على الاقل القبول بالتفاوض
في تقدير الان المؤشرات بشكل او باخر يبان
قبول طلبيه الصراع الجيش والدعم السريع
لمخرجات مؤتمر السودان في القاهره سيتيح
المساحه بشكل جاد وسيدفع طرفيه الصراع
الدعم السريع في القبول بالجلوس والتواصل
الى التفاهمات بمعنى انه مثل هذه القضايا
ايضا بحاجه لموافقه الجيش السوداني ومعلوم
دواما ان الجيش السوداني لديه مواقف مسبقه
بعدم رقبته في التسليم البشير وكذلك عبد
الرحيم محمد حسين واحمد هارون فبالتالي هو
باخر هذه اللعبه المواقف ستشكل عنصر الضخم
مهم جدا وربما تستغل حتى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبعض الاطراف التي ظلت تلعب دور
الوساطه بالازمه السودانيه لتحريك الملف
مرتبط بالتفاوض لكن هذا باي حال من
الاحوال ينبغي ان لا يكون عنصر من عناصر
اخفاء او تجاهل هذه الانتهاكات لان هذه
الانتهاكات لا دور كبير جدا في السلم
والتعايش المجتم عي في دارفور فاذا كان
القضاء السوداني هو غير قادر على تحقيق
العداله في السودان فينبغي لضحايا
الانتهاكات والجرائم والفصعدا يتم نصرهم
وكذلك تقديم مع بعض الحوافز ولو كانت
معنويا باداره
المتهمين او الذين يرتكبوا هذه الفظائح
حتى تكون هنالك بدايه للتعايش سمي باعتبار
مثل هذه الامور وتركها هكذا
وسيجعل مذهله الاستقطاب السياسي وكذلك
الاستقطاب الاذن في دارفور استاذ محمد
وربما من قبل عذرا عذرا اود ان ننتقل
للسيده سوزان عندما تشير الولايات المتحده
الى ان الطرفين لا يرغدان بحل سلميا اقله
في الوقت الحاضر
هل لدى الولايات المتحده هنا رؤيه
مستقبليه او خارطه الطريق لعملها فيما
يتعلق بالملف السوداني
لا يمكنني ان
اقول او اعطي جوابا حاسما انا اقرا واحلل
واتحدث الى زملائي السابق قدر الامكان
ولكن من الصعب جدا
التفاوض حول السلام حين لا يكون هناك فعلا
اهتمام بالجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات كجزء
مما افادت به اللجنه الرباعيه والايجاد
منذ يومين فعلا
هناك حاجه الى عمليه بناء سلام شامله حتى
لا نستمر
بالسماح لقوات الدعم السريع او القوات
المسلحه بان تكون هي الاساس وطرف الرئيسي
المعني يجب ان اعطي الكلمه الى المدنيين
لكي ياتوا فعلا بهذا التغيير الذي تحتاجه
السودان نتحدث عن لجان المقاومه منظمات
نسائيه منظمات الاطباء كل الذين كانوا
يوفرون المساعدات
حين تعذر ذلك على الاسره الدوليه يجب ان
يكونوا مشاركين في هذه
نائبه مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
السابق لشؤون الافريقيه من ميشيغان شكرا
لمحمد تورشين الكاتب والبحث السياسي
السوداني من باريس وشكرا للدكتور بول مرقس
استاذ القانون الدولي ورئيس منظمه جوستسيا
الحقوقيه من بيروت
انتهت حلقتنا شكرا للمتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]